نحن نحقق حاليًا في
أننا نتعاون مع فرنسا
والولايات المتحدة ويقدم أصدقاء آخرون مساعدتهم أيضًا ،
لذا في غضون أيام قليلة
يجب أن نعرف ما حدث وما
حدث بوضوح أن هذا
حادث خطير للغاية لأنه يؤثر على
التجارة البحرية و  إنه يأتي أيضًا في
وقت ما أسميه
فترة حساسة وصعبة في المنطقة ، لذلك من
الواضح أننا جميعًا لدينا مصلحة في هذا
الوقت في خفض التصعيد والتعامل مع
الأمور بطريقة عقلانية ناضجة
تتحدث عن تخفيف التصعيد  الخطاب
مع إيران والحاضر بالتأكيد أعتقد أن
هذا الوضع برمته صعب ،
فنحن في ما نحن فيه إلى حد كبير بسبب
سلوك الإيرانيين الإيراني ،
هذا سلوك ليس جديدًا على المنطقة ،
هذا سلوك تم
تجميعه بشكل أساسي ومن الواضح
الآن  بأنك تعلم أن العقوبات الأمريكية
على إيران لاذعة قال وزير الخارجية
مايك بومبيو إنه في
الأساس لا يريد حربًا مع
إيران ولكن إذا  ked أو إذا تعرضت المصالح الأمريكية
في الشرق الأوسط للهجوم
فإنهم سيردون ، هل أنتم الليلة تحثون
واشنطن على التصرف بدرجة من
الحذر وضبط النفس ، فنحن نشهد
تصعيدًا أعتقد أن المسؤولية تقع على عاتق إيران ،
وأن المسؤولية تقع على عاتق
إيران اليوم.  لقد قادنا السلوك على مدى العقد أو
العقدين الماضيين إلى ما نحن عليه اليوم ،
وهناك ثقة قليلة جدًا
في المنطقة ، ولا أعتقد أن
العبء الآن يقع بشكل أساسي على واشنطن ،
وأعتقد أنه يقع على عاتق إيران ، لقد تحدثت كثيرًا
عن رأي الإيرانيين.  يجب
أن أتساءل عما إذا كان موقفك
بعيدًا عما يجب أن تفعله واشنطن بعد ذلك ،
بالتأكيد الولايات المتحدة والأوربيون
في الوقت الحاضر يثيرون
قلقك في الوقت الحالي ، ومرة أخرى أتساءل عم
إذا كان هذا التحذير من الحذر لا
نبغي أن يكون لواشنطن على ما أعتقد  أن
الشيء المهم هو أن يكون الغرب متحدًا
أكثر فأكثر وأعتقد أن الأمر
يهمنا عندما نرى أن الغرب
يتحدث بأساليب مختلفة ،
أعتقد أن كل هذه البلدان التي لديك
المذكورة توافق على أن هناك مشكلة
في السلوك المعزز
، أعتقد أن الخلاف يدور حول
النهج وأعتقد أن هناك اتفاقًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم على أن إيران كانت
قوة تخريبية